each brother of the Nights Watch swears
a sacred oath to protect the realms of
men
that doesn't mean pissing about waiting
for the cold to finally put an end to
you it means bleeding it means fighting
it means going beyond the wall and
hunting down those who mean harm to the
realm so how do you get a thousand
rapists and thieves to fight together to
bleed together that's the burden of the
Lord Commander he keeps the builders
building the ranges ranging and the
steward stewarding or else it all falls
apart each Lord Commander is chosen from
and by his fellow brothers and he serves
for life a long time ago you may have
had men from Queens Gaede and Long
Barrow and the other sixteen castles of
the wall come to Castle black for an
election these days you'd be looking to
scrape a few dozen from Eastwatch in the
shadow tower or however many they can
spare who cast votes in their stead all
the same
the brothers are allowed to name
whomever they think worthy of the title
then we've all until one man receives a
majority however long it takes some
elections have lasted less than an hour
some of lasted weeks one even lasted two
years maester aemon has said there have
been 997 Lord commanders since the
Nights Watch was founded back then we
are true soleus men of honour and
strength now look who mans the wall
bastards
peasants who stole a shape to bugger and
fat little Nobles who weren't worthy of
the Lord father's land
but the Lord Commander must find a place
for them all and turn these walk-in
piles of or stone into soldiers of the
Nights Watch though haven't always been
so lucky to have such men to lead us
we've had cowards and fools as well
our tyrants and our Mad Men run cyl
Hightower tried to bequeath the watch to
his bastard
Roderick Flint thought to make himself
King beyond the wall
Tristan mood mad mark Rankin fell Robin
Hill each nearly destroyed us with their
foolishness six hundred years ago the
commanders at snow gate in the night
forty even went to war against each
other the simpering Lord Commander asked
them politely to lay aside their quarrel
but incredibly they did because they
join forces to murder him the stark in
Winterfell had to intervene and take
both their heads to save the Nights
Watch now we've got more mouths and we
can feed a southern King in our castle
and cells full of wildlings and no Lord
Commander since the last was betrayed by
his own men we need a new leader a man
respected enough to hold the watch
together in this dark hour a leader
strong enough to make sure that the
Nights Watch survives the coming winter
no matter the cost